Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bird is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in.
Are you?
What's going on?
How are Ya this?
Some happy people out there.
There's some sad people out.
There was a wonderful couple of days of soccer.
Here are all the World Cup
France.
Oh,
Hall Beats Belgium
and England falls to Croatia.
It's calming,
omits calming.
Oh my file.
He looked it up to see like,
why did they keep saying
that it's coming home?
You know,
I immediately assumed like,
well,
obviously England must've won the most championships and this is their arrogant
fucking way of being like,
yeah,
this is where it rightfully belongs.
Kind of like when the Yankees win a world series and then all those fucking
talking heads on on Espn logo and everything is all is right in baseball again.
It's why.
Why?
Because a $200 million team won a fucking playoff series play off.
Turns out that's not what it is.
Evidently the game of soccer.
Now this might our football footie,
whatever the fuck you call it,
evidently it was according to the English,
it was created in England.
They were the ones who decided despite the fact that you have four limbs,
you can only use two.
They wanted a degree of difficulty.
They weren't like the animals over here.
You know where we get bored and I'm like,
pick it up,
you know,
tackle them,
which meant jump on his back and throw him to the fucking ground.
That now a tackle over there.
As you trip,
somebody stick your foot out and you trip up.
So evidently it started over there.
That's what they're saying.
So that's what it meant because I thought it meant that they had the most
championships.
And then I looked up a all time World Cup champions.
All right,
what you got to do?
How the fuck do you not to do?
I don't give a fuck what the sport is.
I to know who dominated it.
Turns out Brazil since 1930 they won the most.
They've won five 58 60 to 794 and 2002 which is a fucking lot considering it's
every four years.
How many there've been one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
91011121314 1520.
This is the 21st one.
They've won 21 like whatever they fucking was that 20% of 25% of them then
Germany?
Yeah,
they,
they got for Italy has four [inaudible] they should have had five in 94.
I remember that one.
Uh,
Argentina hand to God,
that guy,
whatever his name was.
Uh,
the hell was that guy's name?
Diego or some shit.
What the fuck was his name?
I used to know his name.
Yeah.
One of those fucking names where it's just like the second they gave him that
his name,
it's just like pussy is going to be raining down on this guy.
Right.
Um,
I forget the hand of God guy.
That guy.
It was weird.
He was like in shape and he also looked fat.
What the fuck was his name?
Diego.
Eric Gamo was something like that.
I can't fucking remember.
Then,
uh,
I got my hope.
I say this right.
I always,
always Uruguay or go away.
Won it twice.
And then England,
France,
and Spain of all one at once.
That's interesting cause I thought Spain was a powerhouse and I would've thought
in England won a bunch way back in the day when it's probably just a bunch of
white guys running around.
Right?
Yeah.
I also don't want,
so that's why they say it's coming home.
It's not some arrogant shit.
It's like,
Hey,
you know,
this game that the whole world loves,
not to pat ourselves on the back,
but guess what?
We came up with it.
Yeah.
It's our shit.
Okay.
Everything,
you know,
every,
it's not just all about colonization,
the caste system and it's slaving people of other colors around the world.
It's not just about,
that's not all we did.
Okay.
Yay.
Hey,
hey,
you want to focus on the negative?
You could do that.
Okay.
But you can't deny that the beautiful game of football known as soccer over here
in the states.
Okay.
As we sit around eating hobbies.
Right.
Okay.
Was evidently created in England.
I don't know when they did it.
You think for it to have a World Cup by 1934 to sweep the fucking nation.
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
They also had an empire back then.
Oh,
I get it.
So they came up with this game.
They'd come in,
they'd fucking take you over.
They'd fucking kill a bunch of people and everybody was like,
man,
these guys are fucking assholes,
man.
Hi.
Settle down.
Settle down when to teach you a little game.
All right.
You can't use your arms slaughter.
You had your arms chopped off because you couldn't find any gold anyways,
so this is going to work real well for you.
All I can use as your feet and your fucking head
and the game spread like wildfire across the globe
as England expanded her empire.
I never understood why it was considered female.
Was that the tone it down?
That was a bunch of Luna guys going around the world going there.
This is a nice place to live.
Too Bad.
There's other people here.
What can we do about this?
Hi,
everybody does it right.
Everybody's done it since the beginning of time.
You go back,
you go back far enough in history books.
This is what all guilty white people do.
Everybody.
Yeah.
You know Africans enslaved other African jewelry always say that shit,
try get past it.
You know it's like the Billy Joel Song.
We didn't start the fire,
which has got to be the most classic,
the most classic fucking baby boomer response.
I mean what a fucking baby.
He couldn't even take a little bit of responsibility.
Yeah.
You know,
hey,
you know we,
we can start with you and he starts naming all his shit.
Half of it is like pop stars like Marilyn Monroe.
What did she have to do with foreign policy?
I know she fucked a couple of Kennedy's but I mean other than that,
I don't think that dictated whether or not we went into Cuba.
Doris Day fucking [inaudible] to Bubba popup trouble.
Linda sue as the fuck he do.
He must've been on blow when he wrote that song.
It's like,
Billy,
are you going to take any responsibility for this self centered cons that the
baby boom generation was?
I'm not saying everything you did was bad.
I mean,
he invented the Frisbee,
right?
Was that you guys,
who was that the greatest generation.
Okay.
I don't know.
Somewhere in there there's gotta be truth,
right.
From the greatest generation.
Yeah.
You know,
that generation also didn't want to play baseball.
Jackie Robinson,
by the way,
uh,
to the baby boomers who are,
you know,
widely considered the most selfish cunts,
this country has ever produced.
Right.
Just sitting around staring at the navel.
You know,
this is the dawning of the age,
right?
That's the same generation that gave us hippies.
Yeah.
But surely Bergen stocks.
Okay.
You know,
fucking in the mud at a concert.
Yeah.
I used to have a theory way back in the day,
you know,
when they talked about HIV and aids,
they always said that,
you know,
it was some,
somebody,
you know,
it was already somewhat a monkey or some shit and some guy in France.
Got It.
Um,
I never thought it was then.
I used to have a theory that,
you know,
if you watched the woodstocks tapes and you just see all those naked white
people rolling around fucking each other in the mud,
I mean,
he can't tell me that something didn't come out of that,
you know,
at least a stronger strain of the mumps.
Right.
So anyways,
to get back to it,
you know,
I was,
uh,
working,
as an actor.
I was act during the last couple of days and I was talking to this dude going
like,
yeah,
how come England keeps saying it's coming home?
When they were talking about the World Cup and he goes out with his saying those
colonize and constantly fucking dude went off.
I was just like,
you know,
white people,
what,
when we're not all bad.
I mean there's some things,
you know,
Oh,
windows curtains,
you know,
we've done some nice things,
now you can look out your house and see all the,
the lack of opportunity,
right,
right.
From inside your house without white.
Am I actually taking credit for windows?
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
I don't read.
Oh,
speaking of which,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
I said on my last podcast that the Obama's bought an $82 million house.
Turned out it was an eight point $1 million house.
It wasn't even 8.2 million.
That's how off I was it.
This is my favorite thing.
So now all these people like what?
We're all gone.
What did you do?
Your fucking homework man,
like nothing makes people flip out.
Not even religion,
unless you make fun of Muslims,
then those fucking lunatics a liable to do something,
but fucking if you make,
if you make fun of like a Democrat or Republican,
nothing brings people out of the woodworks.
All these people are like,
why don't you do your fucking homework?
Blah Blah.
Which is hilarious.
This whole podcast is based on me not doing any homework,
not reading whatsoever,
so I'm just going to tell you,
you political cuts out there.
You've got a lot of fucking nerve.
A lot.
I just said AIDS came for white people fucking in the mud at Woodstock.
Are you going to come back at me on that one?
What did you do?
Your fucking homework,
man,
this whole podcast exists for one reason and one reason only.
It's to make you feel smarter.
Ice.
We here at the Monday morning podcast and by we,
I mean me in the voices in my head that agree with me.
We hear it.
The Monday morning podcast set the bar so low that even you,
you know with that college that you went to that advertised on television and
you drove yourself there and they like living there was not even an option.
They didn't have dorms.
They just,
you know,
was your college one giant sad building looking like a high school for people in
their twenties yeah.
Yeah.
That's who you are.
And you know what,
even you get to feel smart on this podcast.
So my favorite thing is
if you go back and you listen to
yeah,
my podcasts on Monday when I thought I was so fucking write about the Obamas
buying this $82 million house is somebody actually wrote into the podcast and it
goes,
you know,
Bill,
I love you.
Put,
why don't you do your homework?
Obama just signed a $62 million book deal.
Okay.
And this is what fucking hilarious.
He's telling me to do my homework.
He didn't even do the homework to look up to double check.
What the fuck?
I said even safe if it was true.
He just took it for granted that I said $82 million house and then he's like,
he took that as truth and started looking up the guy's fucking book deal.
So what did she do?
Your fucking homework man.
All right.
For the 9000000th time.
Okay.
On this podcast,
do not take anything I say seriously?
Okay.
You can disagree with their web and you can correct me and all that,
but just don't get upset
and don't be fucking surprised.
Yeah,
that I,
I fucking don't read.
And then might,
my facts might be off.
Okay.
By a good $72 million.
You know that you guys sound like all you fucking political cuts out that bitch
and happy.
You sound like all these fucking fat actresses out here who are bitching about
Hollywood acting as though they're surprised that so much of this fucking
industry is based on how you look.
Okay.
What was that really a shocker?
Had you never been to a movie,
you didn't notice a trend.
Do you think it's just you?
You know what I mean?
And you fucking sloppy tits.
Who's having a rough time?
And I'm a fucking bald redhead and mail.
I have no sympathy for you.
Oh,
he's knocking down their fucking door to put me in an action movie,
you know?
Okay.
I could be hell boy.
Do a fucking cycle of steroids.
I already have the head.
You just fucking paint it red and you're ready to go.
I could do a headstand and fucking my head would turn so red.
You could save feeds the amount of money to save on makeup and time alone.
Okay.
They'll do a fucking handstand.
You're in this seat.
Um,
okay.
Anyways.
Okay.
So I guess the Obamas bought an eight point $1 million house,
not an $82 million house,
which then led me into this whole thing.
Like he's on his,
he's,
this is his third book that he's written.
It's like he was writing books while he was president and you supposed to be
running the fucking country,
fucking sitting there dealing with the Russians and all this terrorist groups
and all that shit.
And then you're like fucking at nighttime.
Okay,
take out a little legal pad.
It was the best of times.
It was the worst of times.
He's fucking assholes out right in the books.
They always get like somebody else.
It's like written by Bill Clinton and the other guy who actually wrote the book.
Yeah.
I want to run a thriller a lot about you and me.
Right?
It right.
Like,
Oh,
you'll put your name and put my name on the cover and then you like write it.
Okay.
What is that book about?
You've got to write what you know.
It's gotta be something about somebody fucking sneak around on his wife.
Right.
Sticking cigars and people.
Oh,
it's too on the nose.
I wanted to be challenged.
I wrote about a guy who was faithful.
Um,
sorry for the bad Bill Clinton.
Uh,
now you guys,
Bill,
why don't you do your homework?
The book is actually bugs experiences,
Oxford,
Oxford in England,
the home where it all started.
Okay.
I take both of those games.
I was working both days,
so I have to go back and watch them and I gotta tell you,
man,
I am so fucking sold on that game though.
I don't know what,
I had so much fun making fun of soccer all these fucking years and it's uh,
it's crazy.
And then watching the highlights,
uh,
when a goal is scored,
like my whole,
my whole complaint about the sport is what makes the sport so great.
The fact that scoring is so God damn difficult.
The fucking,
that the emotion that gets led off when these people score,
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
like in my country,
if you dump a beer on somebody's after some sort of point is scored,
you're going to get into a fight over there.
I mean,
it looked like a fucking,
I don't know what it looked like.
It looked like a,
a sports bar combined with the money shot in a porno.
Everybody's jumping up and down,
just spray in booze all over the place.
Pardon me?
I think it kind of was a little annoying.
Like why,
why,
why are you wasting all that good boots?
You know,
cause I'm a,
I'm,
I'm taking another month off.
You know,
me,
I impose my own little fucking sabbaticals,
you know what I mean?
And after that,
that my little excursion over there to Europe,
oh my God,
there's just I aisle that says sluts Onca 1664 that fucking beer tastes so god
damn good in that Goddamn glass in that one cafe,
uh,
over there in Europe,
over there in France.
Right then I refuse.
I've,
I've seen it over here and I've been tempted to buy it and it's like,
I'm not going to fucking do it because this is what happens.
Like when you go to Ireland and you drink Guinness over there and then he come
back here and you want to continue it.
It fucking sucks.
And you know what else I did?
You know,
it's just unbelievably like,
just on another level is Indian food in England.
I went to this fucking place.
The Indian food was so god good.
I've been,
I,
I've ordered it twice sense that once in France it was okay.
And then I ordered it here in La and it fucking sucked.
Okay.
And I was like,
I got to walk away.
You know,
it's like you go to Paris and he come home and be like,
you know,
I'm going to have a French breakfast.
I'm going to get to Paul Saul.
Right.
And then you'd go down to the fucking supermarket and you get it.
And it's like somebody pulled it out of this shoe,
you know,
it just all goes back to the winning wrong thing.
Yes.
Go on.
Um,
you know what I mean?
That's the only thing that sucks about traveling.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Like A,
I'm,
I think I'm going to do a Gig in buffalo coming up.
I haven't been there in fucking forever.
And what's going to happen is I'm going to go to Duffy's or that other fucking
place where you know where they came up with buffalo wings and I'm going to eat
them and they're going to be so God damn good.
And then I'm going to come back out here.
I'm going to have that fucking crack and my,
my,
my system going,
well,
I'm going to get,
I gotta get some wings out here and when I eat them and they're going to suck.
And then it's just depressing.
You like the only place to get good wings.
It's in Buffalo.
It really is.
I've never gone to any other place other than buffalo that really knows how to
make good buffalo wings.
That's it.
Now I just lob that out there for all of you guys to lose your fucking shit
urge.
You went,
whoa.
You,
you're good.
Okay.
Which you want to do is go to Cincinnati and go to fucking Mfi.
Stay of the best ones.
Okay.
I follow Joe Rogan on all social media and he posted this really fascinating
thing that within 10 minutes I was like,
I don't even know what the fuck this guy's talking about.
He was talking something about fasting
and how it's actually could be good for you.
I mean,
I've read,
Dick Gregory wrote a whole bunch of books on this type of Shit,
right?
Rest his soul and a saying how,
you know,
let's see.
Oregon's rejuvenate and all of that type of shit.
And I thought it was really fascinating.
Until about 10 minutes in,
I realized I,
I didn't understand what the guy was talking about and I looked at him and he
was not in the best of shape.
He looked a little mushy,
you know,
which I would think would happen if you fast it,
you'd get a little fleshy cause your body would keep eating muscle.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
But anyways,
um,
the fuck was my point.
It's talking about food.
Oh Jesus.
I don't fucking know.
I have no idea.
Troubled in the Su is
JFK blown away.
Tips the table over like a fucking baby.
MMM.
Why am I talking about that?
Because I was watching TV late night and I watched all these,
uh,
old 80s
videos
and that song came on,
you know,
I'm telling you,
my new show is 77 sunset strip with Efram Zimbalist jr who I was always a big
fan of cause that FBI show and uh,
end up in,
you know,
I've been made to,
I think yesterday was the first day I snapped while driving in a while and it
felt weird and I immediately
dialed that back down and my move for all you other angry guys out there like me
and you're not angry,
you're not an angry guy.
You just,
that's your default emotion.
Like,
you know what I mean?
I'd like to really be an angry guy.
You just have to be like walking around seeding,
which I don't,
I walk around totally normal and then something happens and I fucking flip out,
you know,
and have a fucking meltdown and then it just takes people.
It's just,
it's so fucking over the top that everybody forgets what a great guy was for the
previous four hours.
That's essentially what it is.
And it's like a fucking five minute meltdown,
you know?
It's like,
what about the other four hours was a good guy?
And it's just like,
no bill.
No what you did in that five minutes negated all that.
It's like doing four hours of fucking cardio and then sitting down and eating a
box of fucking Oreo cookies.
It's just,
it's,
you just negated all of that.
Yeah.
Silver,
you still a fat fuck emotionally.
So anyways,
I,
I listened to baseball.
I listen to the red sox on Sirius Xm and uh,
actually watched.
Then I came home and that's making me watch them again.
Fucking Chris sales up,
guide the beast.
He watched the game last night when he walked that guy,
he didn't think that he walked him and he got fucking mad.
She started throwing like 98,
99 miles an hour on the corners.
That crazy delivery.
Um,
I dunno,
we shall see that.
I don't know who that bum was that they brought into the fucking eighth inning.
Then almost gave me were up four to nothing and he's like,
you know what?
Let's make the gamblers nervous is a nice fatty hanging out over the plate.
Bam,
Bass head boom.
Double four to one load 'em up and they finally got him out of there.
Then our relief pitcher,
I don't know anybody's name,
that guy who comes out there,
he hangs his arm like he's driving a shirt or some shit.
He came out there and shut them the fuck down.
Um,
so I'm,
I'm like a,
I'm back into that shit and I'm actually going to be really sad when the World
Cup's over.
When is the finals that on Saturday,
that's going to be crazy one match for all the fucking models.
Can you imagine if that comes down to penalty kicks again?
I used to think that was the stupidest fucking thing ever.
Like a world bass,
like a basketball championship coming down to foul shots,
you know what I mean?
That would just be like boring as shit.
But now I get it.
I get it because if you fuck it up,
I really feel like the goaltender has like no pressure cause all he has to do is
just guess,
you know,
I love that they're guessing it's just a total guests.
And when they guess,
right,
they guess,
right.
They stand up like,
like there was some sort of intelligent thought there.
It's just like left,
right,
left,
right diving left.
Fucky went right.
Um,
that always,
it's always funny when they guess wrong when they're,
they start to dive that way and they realize that guy went the other way and you
just watched the goaltender,
like his whole body goes limp.
Like,
ah,
I should tell the other way.
And he just fucking landed on the grass.
But the pressure on the shooter,
they don't want to miss the net.
So I,
I'm gathering it takes massive balls to try to shoot it up top to go top corner,
which why wouldn't you just go there?
He's not going to fucking get that.
Cause it's like,
what if I miss then I'm that cunt that fucking missed for the rest of my fucking
life in fat,
crooked,
great teeth,
fishing ship.
Eaton fucking assholes can get my grill everywhere I go for the rest of my life.
People who never accomplish shit now can take out the failure of their life on
me cause I tried to go top shelf.
What do you guys call it?
What do we,
what do you guys call shelves over there?
The the boot.
What the fuck do you always have some stupid fucking name for it?
Um,
I've got to send on cooking shows.
Every ingredient you guys pronounce differently.
Oregano or Rogano,
tomato,
tomato.
Bazell Basel Second.
They just fucking with me.
There wasn't one thing.
Did we hate England that much?
By the end of it,
I really think that we would like to summer school kids that came over here in
like the weird religious people.
Yeah.
We all came over here and you had people who weren't good in school.
Fucking people that were too into religion and those two people combine made
Americans.
That's why I am the product of that.
And I thought an eight point $1 million house was $82 million.
Why don't you do your homework but you go fuck yourself.
Do my homework.
I'm not in fucking school.
Alright,
only getting this.
There's business to thank.
All right,
let me,
let me read it.
A little bit of advertising here.
JFK blown away.
The tipping over for can table.
I still love Billy Joel cause he got so hammered he drove his car through his
fucking neighbor's living room window.
I mean can yet,
can you loan him enough sugar in your lifetime to get past that?
You know,
every day I'd be knocking on the door.
Hey Man,
if you want to borrow a rake or a wheel barrow,
anything,
anything you,
you know Barrow by the way,
not barrel roll out the Barrow where Ray can some fuck and leaves.
By the way,
Dean del Ray from the letter B talk podcast on all things.
Comedy has the legendary Henry Rollins on his podcasts this week.
This is a dream guest for Dean del race.
He'd want to listen to him fanboy out while asking all the questions.
You always wanted to hear Henry Rollins answer.
Give a take a few.
Um,
check it out in the all things coming network.
Let there be talk.
Dean del Rey with the Great Henry Rollins who had such a funny bit on iron
maiden,
he actually made me question whether I was a moron for liking the band.
And then of course I put on one of their songs and I was like,
no,
I wasn't.
I wasn't
right.
It sounds,
uh,
we read this book about a bloke who had wings and he flew too close to the sun.
So there's songs about a bloke who put some wings on and flew too close to the
sun.
Um,
all right.
Butcher box.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken.
And this is right.
This is the money shot right here.
And heritage bread,
pork,
the best God,
the import shop I've ever had in my life that I ever made in my house,
I think maybe one time and went to some five star restaurant.
You know the rep fucking chefs walking around wearing clogs.
You got to go to one of those places,
you know,
and there's all these old bald guys like me with these skinny young broads,
Aka their second or third wife.
You know,
you gotta go to a place like that.
If you don't want to drop that kind of cash and you still want the best pork
chop you ever going to have,
you got to get butchered bucks.
All right there.
There's my personal farther that I just made it personal.
Okay?
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones before they kill
them.
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
You could feed a fucking army.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Go crazy,
man.
Throws many animals in there.
As you can custom box let you choose your own cuts.
Come on,
man.
It's the fucking,
get the grill.
Go and get some butcher box.
This ad always makes me hungry.
That's how good the food has been.
A antibiotic slash hormone free butcher box believes in healthier food system
where everyone has access to meets the way nature intended.
Now,
like these cows and mainstream where they got the fake tits and the fucking
botox.
All right,
and you want the original ones,
free of antibiotics and hormones and humanely raised on open pasture.
Let them walk around.
Um,
selection is amazing.
Bushbucks carefully curates the finest selection and cuts and makes it a breeze
to customize your own delivery.
Build your own box to get exactly what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency with the customization.
It's uh,
with customizable subscription recipes are available on butcher box.
Has websites and videos are available to fall along a bunch of bugs.
You can't fucking lose all rights to receive free bacon for life.
The dream of every goddamn meat eater out there,
plus $10 off your order.
Go to butcher box.com.
Click on the big bacon banner on the homepage and use bur at checkout.
Go now,
limited time offer.
All right.
Four sigmatic that that's said Stigmata
this episode is brought to you by four sigmatic four sigmatic the leading online
purveyors of shrooms,
man.
That's right.
There's Shalon shrooms on the Internet,
but really this company sells mushroom coffee that actually tastes great.
It is damn good for you.
I fucking love mushrooms.
I would actually try this.
You know,
I love mushroom soup.
I've always wanted to try mushrooms.
You know,
I know.
I know where you're going to say.
Talk to Ari.
Shaffir four sigmatic um,
is from Finland,
so you know,
it's good.
The same country that gave you Santa Claus.
Angry beards
go ROSC.
I hit,
I would say as the goaltender for the Boston Bruins.
Like he didn't already know that.
And of course,
mushroom coffee.
Did you know that?
Finished people consume more coffee per capita than any other country?
Almost three times more than Americans.
I don't like that.
We're losing to them.
And coffee.
Mushroom coffee has half the caffeine of regular coffee,
but it's twice as magical.
It's easy on the gut,
less acidic,
and you don't get the jittery feeling you get from regular coffee.
Dude,
I'm sold.
I'd love a nice hot cup of fucking mushroom coffee right now.
Um,
evidently I'm drinking the mushroom coffee with lion's Mane and Chaga.
Lion's mane.
There's hair in the fucking coffee.
Tastes just like coffee.
Not like mushrooms.
Oh,
ah,
okay.
All they told me,
not to say it tastes like mushrooms,
I guess it doesn't.
It tastes like coffee.
Lion's mane.
Mushroom is your brain's best friend,
long used by Buddhist monks.
They never lose their shit.
Right.
To help with focus during meditation.
I got to try this shit perfect for when I need to get shit done.
Think of it as supercharged instant coffee come.
I think how this is all in the past tense like I've done this in my life has
changed for the better,
but I'm sold coming easy to use carry single serving packets.
Perfect to take to work for travel or when you're on the go get 50% off.
Your first purchase with code burpee you are are just go do foursigmatic.com and
try it out for yourself.
Yeah.
You know,
nausea is going to come out with his coat,
his own coffee called for illmatic,
right.
Excuse me.
Made with,
I don't know,
maybe we'd and mushrooms.
I don't know.
Is he into that shit?
I have no idea.
Uh,
me undies,
um,
me undies are made with a sustainably sourced material.
Oh wait a minute.
[inaudible] me undies.
BRD is the World Cup is in home.
Doodoodoo to Biondi is beyond these is sick of fucking being alone.
But then England lost through the Croatians.
Now that cup is still on vacation and a coming.
Oh man,
he fucking time sown.
Sorry to everybody over there.
Congratulations.
Crow.
A show.
I love that.
Number 10 number 10 on Croatia.
That fucking guy is a play.
Um,
France has a great team.
I don't know who to root for here.
I obviously love France.
Patty.
Oh,
I have a great time when I'm over there,
but I gotta tell you,
man,
the Croatian,
some good looking God damn people and it's only 4.1 million of them.
According to Pete Davidson.
There's more people in New York City,
then there's in their entire country and they are in the finals.
So I think I kind of have to root for them
cause they're the underdogs again.
No,
fuck it.
I'll run for Croatia.
Okay.
All right.
How does it like gotta get I to hear their national anthem?
I got to learn that by Saturday.
Oh,
fucking Croatia is only 4 million cards.
Croatia National National Ffa.
I was from fucking anthem.
Anthem.
You know this is going to be some fucking Dracula,
Eastern European shit.
Oh,
by the way,
that tourists is going down.
I'm getting all the dates.
Okay.
I'm not talking shit.
I'm going out there.
Croatian national anthem with English lyrics.
That's not very probation,
is it?
What do they speak over their cro?
okay.
All right.
Okay.
Oh,
it's only two and a half minutes long.
I'm already liking this.
It's like a Beatle song.
Yeah.
Well where's the fucking,
where's the music?
It's scrolling.
Scrolling.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
There's no fucking way I'm going to be able to in this.
Ah,
right.
And it comes down.
Ooh.
It's very cinematic.
Okay.
You know what?
I like it.
God Damn it.
It's very cinematic.
Um,
okay.
I like ours too.
I was a big deal.
It's based off a drinking song.
You know we did,
we pulled the Jimmy page when we wrote it like out on the tiles.
I guess Jason Bond.
I'm told that story home.
That's super group show on VH one way back in the day.
Right.
Okay.
That I'm out on the tiles.
[inaudible] Nana what?
Bay WePay WePay bag dead.
Dead.
Dead Go.
Pacheoco Beko but Dadda Dadda ba Ba da Ba da Ba da Ba da Ba debit.
But that,
um,
that was actually a drink at song.
I'm out on the towels.
I had a little Jig and have some men of something and I'm out on the towels.
So Jimmy just,
you know,
I guess John came in singing that and Jimmy's like Raleigh.
What's said?
Sony has already been written,
um,
me undies me undies are made was sustainably source material from beechwood
trees.
They're naturally sof.
Yeah,
it makes a fabric that won't sag down a ride up.
Trust me.
Once you put on a pair,
you'll get it.
Feel free to improvise here.
A boy.
What you love about me undies.
I love the way it cradles my fucking nuts.
Me undies is so sure you'll love your first pair.
If you're not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you into the right pair.
They'll send a fucking horny and had another one.
And if they can't
keep them and they'll refund you.
So it's really is risk risk-free.
Try the best underwear ever.
And if you're already part of the Mian these fam,
what up fam?
Tell your friends about it through their referral program.
They'll get a discount and you'll get a store credit when,
when it's like Amway meets fucking underwear.
Still not sure.
Well me undies has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers get dean percent off their first pair of me undies and
shipping is free.
That's 15% off plus free shipping and a guarantee that you and your me undies,
we'll be happy to get.
Uh,
I can't see me wearing no undies,
bud.
These against mine balls.
Get your butt over to me undies.
Dot.
Come and treat yourself,
um,
me and you and you in me to get your 15% off your first pair for free shipping
at a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's me,
undies com slash bar and lastly,
but not leastly,
he looks.com.
Oh,
after this I'm going to tell you about my standup set I had last night.
Uh,
there's nobody on the planet like you.
You're special.
You have something to say.
And by all means,
please emote about it on social media.
You know,
I actually tweeted about this on the Twitter there.
They actually had a Hashtag a hashtag things I don't tolerate.
Oh my God.
It had to be the most self serving fucking thing ever since.
Just as such an excuse for everybody to see what a wonderful open minded person
you are.
Things they don't tolerate.
Big,
itchy mean people Pili yet pick and people who are weaker,
you know,
is that all obvious shift hashtag things that tastes good.
Ice Cream,
cookies,
um,
helix.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
So why the fuck would you buy a generic mattress built for everyone else?
Maybe cause you hate shopping.
I don't know.
Next,
please mention all the talking points below.
Well,
I will,
if you're right it,
I'll read it.
Helic sleep matches your body to the perfect mattress so you get the best sleep
of your life.
They developed nine different mattresses tailored to specific specific body
types and sleep preferences.
All right,
so everybody's different,
but there's only nine different designs.
Maybe there's all kinds of offshoots.
You know,
like everybody else,
you're like one in nine people.
Uh,
just go to a Heloc,
sleep.com/burr take their two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll match you to a mattress that's perfect for you conquering your body
to provide unprecedented and better sleep.
30% of Helix sleep customers report better sleep after switching to their
customized mattress from heloc sleep.
Right now they're offering,
hey Neil,
what's up?
Come here.
The lovely knee,
everybody for up to $125 off all mattress orders.
Nia,
do you realize that you're a unique human being?
Yes.
Your unique human being.
You're only like one out of every nine people.
One out of every nine.
Well,
these guys make unique mattress and the EAA said everybody's the same,
but they have nine different mattress types.
Oh,
that's Hellickson,
Kate,
to get 125 wait,
is it hell no,
I'm confused.
I don't know either.
They never told me he looks,
oh,
I feel like I knew this and now I don't remember.
Hey,
you finished reading this.
Whether you're a side sleeper,
hot sleeper,
like a plush or fun bed.
They've got the mattress that will fit just right.
Get up to 125% off at Helix.
sleep.com/.
Burn.
That's the Heloc.
sleep.com/burn for $125 off your mattress order.
He looks sleep.com/burr.
There you go.
Yeah.
Does it rhyme with Felix?
I don't think it does.
I think it's Hallux.
I feel like I knew this.
I feel like I gave you shit about it.
Oh,
okay.
And now I don't remember.
Now you don't remember?
Hey,
so last night
I went,
last night I was out and about,
I went to a bobcat.
Goldthwait has a new show on true TV called bobcat.
Goldthwait.
Uh,
was it monsters and um,
Miss Smith's misfits in monster,
something like that.
I don't know what it is,
but it's on true TV.
I watched an episode of it last night.
It's fucking,
it's classic bobcat.
It's totally original.
If you just look up,
if you just search bobcat Goldthwait right.
If you do that,
you're going to find it's on true TV.
What was the last name?
What was the last night?
Wednesday.
Yes.
So Wednesday night at 10 o'clock on true TV.
That's all right.
There you go.
So I went down to the premiere.
I got there late because I was working as an actor.
I had to take off my little fucking tights when I was done acting.
Yeah.
I was feeling guilty because I wanted to go down there.
I had friends,
I had to see them,
but I hadn't done standup in a minute.
And I'm going to be in Portland and Seattle this weekend,
so I got to shake the fucking rust off.
I wish I could go to Portland and Seattle with you.
Well Nia,
it's only a southwest or Alaskan flight away.
Yeah.
I want to go.
I want to have a friend in Portland.
I've always wanted to see Portland and I just feel like the microphone is so
close to my right.
Oh,
sorry.
Um,
yeah.
And I've never been to Seattle either.
Both ways.
I've been wanting to go.
I invited you.
Yeah.
You then can I get back to my story?
Oh,
sorry.
So this is what I love about La.
So I'm walking out,
I ubered over right,
smoked a cigar with one of my great friends in this business.
And then I was walking out on APP,
man,
I didn't do standup.
Should I pause fucking Uber over there and then Uber home.
Fuck this.
So I just start walking home and I walked by a fucking who does?
And there was these young comics parking up front,
a comedy show come and they saw me coming down the street and they laugh,
hey,
want to go to a comedy show?
I said,
no.
And they go,
do you want to go up?
I'm like,
Nah,
thank you though.
And then I walked about 10 feet.
I was like,
fuck it,
I need to get a set in.
And I went in there and I did a set at Hooters last night upstairs in the big
room,
in the main room.
It was a bunch of young kids there while you were there?
No.
What about the buffalo shrimp,
Nina?
I literally walked in.
It was awesome.
They put me on like the fucking president.
They put me on immediately.
I went up.
I did 'em of course,
Bill,
everybody knows you at Hooters.
I um,
I went on and I said,
I do 10 to 15.
I feel like I did around 12.
That felt like a 12.
I got my labs,
I shook the rust off and I fucking walked out.
It was great.
It was perfect.
Then I walked out,
walked halfway down the block and there was a taxi,
which I love old school,
and I got into it.
I say,
you work in?
And he goes,
he goes,
yes.
And I got in,
I got,
I ain't doing,
he goes,
yeah.
So,
so I was like,
all right,
I appreciate that.
And he goes,
and he left this mother fucker where they fucking fucking drive it home.
Just curse.
I can be myself just cursing everybody in the way.
That night.
Last night,
I had a great night.
Yes.
Without alcohol.
I don't need it,
man.
Can we just talk about Hooters for a second?
I really love the Buffalo Shrimp.
Yeah,
it's swamp with buffalo sauce.
It's just like,
oh.
And they give you like this blue cheese dipping sauce to go with it.
Oh my God.
It's too blue cheese is the most disgusting.
One of one of the more disgusting foods.
You know that we watch an undercover brother and they were talking about how
white people like white people,
like very underrated movie by the way.
So funny.
Yeah.
How um,
white people like Manet's and evidently black people don't.
I don't fucking know my whatever.
I Dunno what I like Manet's within reason.
I like man,
he's like,
man,
he's on fries.
I like mayonnaise on roast beef.
I like eating Manet's in front of people that don't enjoy Manet's.
Um,
no,
I like a buy blue cheese is just fuck God.
It's like
Buffalo shrimp and,
and blue cheese dressing on my God.
It's just like,
it's like a mucus.
It's gross.
I think when you eat wings,
you're just eat the wing cause you don't even use any of this sauce.
No rant.
What about ranch?
What are your feelings about ranch?
Oh,
it's all right.
I just
know,
I know for a man he is,
you know,
I like ketchup.
I like mayonnaise.
Mustard.
I like the basic hair.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a basic white dude.
I like pickles.
Yup.
Uh,
I like a snake.
Here's,
here's a nice little surprise here as you can see that I've traveled.
I like a stuffed.
All of,
does that make me interesting?
My walking it out to you was that some dance?
They didn't land it from years ago.
Oh God,
I'm on Instagram.
I know all the latest dances are really neat and once you get up and do the
mashed potato for me,
I got to get you to do a a in my feelings challenge.
All right,
go ahead and do it.
Well,
the dance,
you got to play the song to dance.
It's a dance that you do to a Drake song called in my feelings.
I can't stand Drake.
Do you love me?
Are you riding?
You haven't seen it.
I can't.
I can't stand that guy.
Not Literally that guy you used to,
you used to like Drake.
He used to always whining about somebody.
It's just like he,
he's got this great life.
He's banging models and I got to sit there and listen to him whine about the
model that he used to fuck.
Who doesn't call them back anymore?
It's like Drake.
You were just fucking her.
She moved on.
He's emotional.
He isn't.
He's selfish.
Um,
but he loves magic magic.
I've seen like three different videos of him running away after a trick.
That's what's really funny about black people as you can.
You can see somebody hustling you lying to you and all that type of shit.
You know,
like you just,
you can smell bullshit from a mile of fucking way,
but you get a magician does a card trick.
You guys run away like he's a witch.
What the fuck was that?
Yeah,
cause that's that devil shit.
It's that.
It's of hand near all that.
Oh No,
that's the devil.
Yeah.
If that guy could do that shit,
if that guy could do that shit,
he would just fucking like levitate into a bank vault.
You wouldn't be fucking hustle and doing magic on a street corner.
Right.
It's still
it just playing with evil forces with the magic shit.
All right.
Playing with evil forces with the magic shit.
You heard that that should be on a tee shirt
plain with the evil forces,
with the magic shit
that has to be in a rap song has to be in something I don't like hate Drake.
I just like,
his fucking music is just like,
you don't,
you don't like this guys that just call up and they just dump your day the day
on you.
It's just like,
do you ever in a good mood
what happened now Drake,
a lot of problems.
People are coming for him.
They're trying to expose,
you know,
his family life that he was trying to keep private,
you know?
Yeah.
That's none of my business.
All him anymore.
That was weak.
That was a week doing that shit.
We didn't start the fire.
All right.
I gotta get,
I gotta get off my day.
Oh my God.
I hate that
Charlie Chaplin.
Teddy Roosevelt fucking people from the past.
Bob Apo,
but Dopa to bell.
Stop fucking avoiding the topic.
Second generation did a lot of shitty things.
Trouble.
It's the worst line ever.
All right.
Having said that,
I love,
I like a lot of his songs.
I feel like you don't talk enough about stuff that you enjoy it.
I feel like you're now going to talk about what you don't like about me in the
relationship.
Okay.
Yup.
So I feel like coming up about the things that you like.
You always talking about what you can don't like and I just see what's going on
and on how,
I love soccer and I hated soccer and I love it.
But there's been this whole fucking transformation.
Yeah,
I missed that pile because you focus on the negative.
No,
I think you have a nice size.
He's such a hassle.
We finally became friends again.
We're buddies again because of the work that I've put in.
Like,
excuse me,
what about me?
No,
I told you you becoming like this goth chick that shops at hot topic.
That was your vibe.
Gloom and doom.
A lot of really a modern references.
Did they?
Do they not exist anymore?
I don't know.
Do they?
And I dunno.
I haven't been to them on a while,
so fuck you haven't,
last time I talked to you,
where are you?
I'm ethic grove.
Oh yeah.
But they don't have a hot topic.
So do they still exist?
I Dunno.
They're high end.
All right,
go ahead.
Shit on me.
What do you got?
No,
no,
you're right.
We're friends again after having a little moment there.
So now I'm going to keep it positive.
I think you're great.
I think that you're are stick with the devil shit with the creepy vibes or
whatever the fuck you said.
Um,
oh God.
Anyways,
I was trying to end on an upbeat note.
Who Wore it better?
The Marvin Gaye beard Drake or Marvin Gaye.
Marvin Gaye obviously rock the Marvin Gaye beard.
Better than Drake would.
Who wore that red hat better?
Marvin Gaye.
Jacques Cousteau.
And now my goal is to try to get you not to say Marvin Gaye.
Um,
who is more important?
You know what?
I can't go that route.
You'll get upset with that one.
I didn't even have anything there.
What'd you have to keep saying Marvin Gaye?
It's an Improv thing.
You should have gone to Jacques Cousteau then I could have gone the French way.
I had the ocean outlet.
You just paid me into a corner.
Oh,
so it's my fault that you're not,
I dunno.
Good at Improv.
Yeah.
I killed upstairs in the big room and didn't even bother to get buffalo shrimp.
It's like,
yeah,
I was too busy killing upstairs.
Eto.
Hooter so when is your next Hooters,
the,
at the Hooters in Hollywood and in the big room?
Well,
I guess they're moved,
they're moving their show across the street to looters.
I don't fucking know.
Whatever's across the street did fucking Hollywood boulevard,
you know,
we didn't have,
we didn't have any fire for the cigars there,
so I had to go into tourist play,
have had fire is that we rubbed some matches fucking to gather.
Um,
and went into one of those touristy places and I bought a,
I love California lighter for my buddy who hates la,
which is worked twice and then it broke.
It was like three bucks and then it ran out of lighter fluid.
They're so cheap.
All those,
like they're always going,
hey man,
we got souvenirs for $5.
It's like,
no,
you need to be solidly souvenirs for 50 cents,
if that.
My favorite thing is when you go to New York and they have that,
you know,
that that foam rubber thing where you wear the crown from the fucking statue of
Liberty.
People walk around with that.
Like I went to New York and I got this.
Can you imagine how many those are floating around the fucking ocean?
Some poor fucking porpoises trying to swallow that thing.
All right,
we're out.
I'm out of time here cause I got,
I got shit to do here.
Or is it 52 minutes?
Um,
thank you for coming on here in bringing the positivity.
I try.
I'll do better next time.
You did great with the devil shit with the evil stuff over there.
Whatever the fuck you said.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Thank you everybody for listening.
Uh,
you know,
my apologies to anybody out there who is a friend of mine.
Um,
I don't apologize.
All right.
That's something that a mature adult does.
Uh,
please enjoy the music and a half hour of a greatest hits from a Thursday
afternoon podcasts just before Friday,
Monday morning
podcast,
whatever the fuck I say,
and have a great couple of days.
You can send a check in on your Thursday,
you'll fine.
I
imagine
travel as much as
some of us,
some of us live in houses,
some of the light,
you guys see that coming.
I just saw a commercial
for Kentucky Fried Chicken where the parents are all excited because the two
bratty kids won't sit still at the dinner table,
but they got them this fucking chicken and they're feeding it to and they're
basically very suddenly saying that there's drugs in this chicken that will make
you a spastic children.
Chill the fuck out and spastic.
I mean like,
you know,
not,
not the way they mean it over there.
And Great Britain.
You can't say that on the comedy.
So you can say it in a comedy club over in Scotland,
but you'll have a rough,
they'll have a rough go of it.
If you say the kid was spastic over there,
that means like severely mentally challenged over here.
It just means you're not going to get laid to you 26
when you were in Grad school looking over a fucking cadaver,
right,
with some other fucking nerve narrowed.
Right.
And you're just sitting there going,
you know the ankle bones connected to the knee bone,
right.
Has any of this made any sense?
What shouldn't?
It's fucking Sunday night and I am spent and I got a whole bunch of Shit I have
to do tomorrow,
so I got to do it tonight.
All right,
I'm off my game.
you,
you cleanse your liver and like 42 43 days or something like that.
Every drunk I knows has told me that if he drunk,
I know that does not have a medical degree.
Has told me that if you go 42 43 days,
you will cleanse your liver at least to the booze.
You know?
Now if you fucking,
you start doing blow or a,
you know,
eating a bunch of trans fat fucking food,
a feeding your kids,
Kentucky Fried fucking chicken,
Jesus Christ.
What happened to parents and she got a drug,
your kids to keep them under control,
you know,
you know what it is.
Kids don't respect their parents,
they respect them,
but they don't respect like,
oh my God,
this,
this person could wring my neck,
could pick me up by my hair.
Right.
Could grab a paddle and fucking,
you know,
mostly hit my ass,
but also kinda hit my lower back because I'm squirming right.
That doesn't exist anymore.
So now these kids is so fucking out of control.
These people have to go down to Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Okay.
And I,
I,
I used the term chicken very loosely to go down in whatever that is that's in
that bucket.
Okay?
It doesn't have a beak.
It doesn't have feet.
If it's fucking,
you know,
chest,
his breasts to stick it out like the cast on fucking,
uh,
what was,
what was that show with the Italians there on New Jersey Shore Jersey shore.
Right.
My world.
That's not a fucking chicken.
You know,
you want the chicken that looked like Mark McGuire and his rookie season.
You don't want to eat the chicken that looks like mark McGwire when he fucking
played for the cardinals.
You know?
Do you eat a regular fucking chicken?
First of all,
it's going to look like a pigeon tea because you so used to seeing those roid it
up once that they have murderer's row that you got down there at your fucking
Shaws,
right?
You Vaughn's you,
JC pennys,
wherever the fuck you buy your God damn check it.
You go down,
you go down to any one of the main stream fucking supermarkets.
Okay.
And I swear to God when you get to the chicken section,
okay,
if you've,
if you've slept for the last 30 years,
like that Van Gundy guy under the bridge,
whatever his fucking name is,
Van Morrison,
the hell's his name,
Rip Van Winkle.
Right.
It was one of those people,
one of the vans.
Um,
okay.
If you slept for the last 30 years and you went down,
And they showed you what a chicken wants,
you'd be like,
that ain't no chicken.
Okay?
It's a God damn Turkey.
I know.
Fuck Dyno
fucking Turkey.
When I say what?
I ain't no such thing as a math path.
Fucking chicken can't be done.
No Sir.
Get off my property.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm done with your witchcraft.
Okay.
Hey,
I said,
get the fuck Outta here.
Okay.
Fuck off my property.
MMM
honey,
get the gun.
Um,
yeah,
you would think it was a fucking Turkey.
And the thing is,
is now it's a chicken.
And I remember I watched one of those food banks,
one of those fucking liberal Goddamn thinks,
you know,
talking about flying carpets and electric roads and all that bullshit.
Somewhere in there they were talking about,
you know,
the food supply and I'll poison it is poisonous
poisoning.
And it is,
it is.
Um,
so I fucking went down to a farmer's fucking mark yet.
And um,
I said,
I wanna,
I wanna all I want.
I want to,
I want it all
natural fucking chicken.
I can't even talk.
I'm so tired.
One an all natural chicken.
The guy goes,
these are all natural.
And I said,
all natural.
And he goes,
well,
I'm like,
come on,
where is it?
And he had to walk around the corner sitting over there,
lonely.
I swear to God,
looking like a dove look like in somebody killed the fucking dump.
Because right there,
that one right there is 100% all natural.
Nothing's wrong with it.
And I was like,
I was like,
what?
That's what a chicken is supposed to look like.
And he raised his eyebrows and he,
he kind of put his lips together so they were straight line.
And then he nodded,
you know,
that looked at people do like,
like,
yeah,
I'm in the Matrix.
I realize I'm in the Matrix,
you know,
I knocked the bitch up so I got to be selling these,
wrote it up.
Chickens.
No.
Um,
anyways,
anyway,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
So basically that's what these people are eating over there.
Okay.
They are,
they are drug and up
the kids,
but I can't get mad at him because I actually did that to Charlie Murphy and a
Don l Rawlings.
I've told this story before,
Hey,
I'll tell it against my fucking podcast.
I actually drug I the exact thing that they're doing in that Kentucky Fried
Chicken commercial with it,
trying to get the kids to sit still by just feeding him so full of these fucking
trans fats from these Roy up beatless fucking chickens with the Dolly Parton
breast diseases.
Right.
I did that to fucking Donnelle and Charlie,
I was hung over and we've taken a car service from Chicago xannies up to one of
those whenever the fuck it was
Saint Charles,
it was a three city run
and one of them was Saint Charles.
So we're getting in the fucking Limo,
Don L's in rare form.
Charlie's in rare form.
They're fucking Gavin and trash and people and me and everybody and I just don't
want to hear it.
I'm like,
I don't want to listen to these fucking guys running that Goddamn yaps in the
back of this car the whole fucking way up.
I want a nice quiet ride.
This is going to suck.
And I walked outside,
hung over and I walked into the Chicago where,
you know,
almost got hit by three fat people.
And,
um,
I looked up to street and I saw it,
I saw a Popeye's and I was like,
oh,
thank God.
And I fucking walked in there and I got all this fucking Popeye's chicken with
biscuits and all of this shit food.
And I brought it back to the car and as the car pulled up,
they came out and I say,
guys,
I got to sell some.
I got some food.
And they like,
ah,
it's fucking great.
You know,
they were hungry or whatever.
And they started showering that fucking Popeye's food and I sat back,
nibbling on a drum stick
and I swear to God,
10 minutes later they were asleep.
I'm not lying to you.
They were fucking asleep,
snoring the whole way up.
And I was just sitting there loving life,
the whole fucking write up.
And I,
you know what,
I admitted to him later,
they thought it was funny,
but that's basic what it is.
They called it the Itis,
that's what they call it when you eat that shit food and then you have to go to
sleep,
they call it the Itis,
I guess.
And by they,
I meet African Americans.
Um,
they call it the fucking Itus and that's what they got.
And the F and I learned that from Don l because I don't know how that man stayed
in shape,
but he had the worst diet.
He's one of those guys who like you stopped for gas and he comes out of the gas
station with like one of those gas station hot dogs.
And he would eat it and then he would immediately fall asleep.
And I,
and I would say to Charlie,
look at this guy,
he's sleeping and chat and be like,
yeah man,
he got the itis me.
Explain that to me and what that little bit of information,
it went into my evil white brain and I drug my two African American friends way
back in the year 2005.
Um,
and that's a little chicken story for you.
What time did you like that?
Everybody.
So that's what the fuck they're saying right there.
That's what Kentucky Fried Chicken is allegedly saying.
I guess they have to say a legend.
So their lawyers on retainer don't attack my fucking podcast as far as I can
tell.
I'm asking you right now,
uh,
Kentucky Fried Chicken hiding behind your fucking letters,
KFC.
Is that what the fuck you do?
Is that what you're saying?
If you've got kids who are not stimulated enough that they can't even sit down,
if you have a Reia of running around,
you got to tie your kids out,
opened the door.
You send them out in the fucking yard.
God,
God side,
get outside and play.
That's what you do.
Like a God damn one of those fucking Irish dogs.
It was bread dip too to herd sheep.
You've got to let that fucking thing run around.
Run around in circles.
Guy,
get out there,
take a ball.
You just fucking throw it out and traffic.
Let the dog run around.
Dodgy cars.
It comes in,
it's going to lay down.
Okay?
It's not going to jump all over.
Company stick and it's cold nose,
right in their fucking who has.
That's what you got to do with your kids.
You've got to send them upside,
right?
But to catch a Predator and all these other fucking shows,
you know,
all these shows on TV where people forget that kids are in a car with the
windows rolled up and the kids are too fucking dumb to roll them down or they're
too weak because they haven't gone outside and climb to fucking tree and they
stay in there and then their,
their brains get cooked like a boxer,
you know?
Yeah.
You know that dog boxes,
they don't,
they don't do well in the sun.
Well,
we'll need to do fat kids.
If you leave the windows rolled up,
you know,
and they got those weak arms that all of that think the most tedious things they
ever did was take a wrapper off of a fucking,
uh,
an ice cream sandwich.
Right.
You can't leave them in the car.
My mother left us in the car all the fucking time.
She would go to school.
She was going to school during the day trying to further her education and she
left five fucking kids in the car with the windows rolled up and money for
Burger King.
And she would say to us,
just go into the Burger.
That's the only time you were to leave this car overlay over the next three
fucking hours when I'm in class.
And she would disappear around the corner after we set.
Absolutely.
Mom and she walked away.
Ed.
Uh,
we immediately would get out of the car,
start walking up and down the streets in Boston.
Okay.
We go into fucking burger king and we,
we'd have some to eat.
Do you know what would happen nowadays if they just saw five fucking dirty face
kids walking up and down,
calm AV Boylston street going into a burger king looking like the cast to
fucking Annie.
Okay.
Someone would have filmed it and my mother would have been in,
they would have taken us away,
you know,
but,
but they didn't
cause there was no cameras back then or videotape ones.
I mean there was,
but only people add them on like the news.
Yeah.
And a young Steven Spielberg.
So we went in there and we fucking got some food,
climbed on cars and fucking yelled at people and Shit.
Ditto hanging on Platt parking meters.
And all that.
Hence,
we had the fucking forearm strength to roll down the windows and none of us ever
had an issue in the car.
And you know what?
I think that's one to grow on today.
You go people,
I'm not saying KFC is food.
I'm not,
I'm just kidding.
I'm not saying it's bad food.
Every once in a while who's kitten home?
He wants to,
we don't go anywhere.
Be Great.
If he could just fucking do heroin the way you can eat Mcdonald's,
just like every once in a while he'd just be like,
you know what?
Yeah,
let's just fucking tie off.
Not off for the rest of the fucking day in like the people at work understood
it.
Okay.
You know?
Hey,
where were you yesterday on?
Yeah,
I got this black tar heroin came in.
You know,
I hadn't done it like three months away.
Figured fuck it.
Oh,
is that what you did?
How was it?
You know,
like you're like you went to Aruba,
you said,
oh,
I've towed.
It was awesome.
I don't remember shit.
You know,
he'd get a dick.
That's fine.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 12th,
all la.
I'm sorry.
I was really going to act like I could speak Spanish there.
Oh,
allow yo soy comical and anemia.
Maybe Litchi
ornaments.
Santa's bent alone is Una COMESA.
I actually,
if you can't tell,
I've actually finally broken open my Rosetta stone that I got for Christmas two
and a half fucking years ago or whatever it is.
Yeah,
I got it for a year and a half ago.
December of 2008 I got a the Rosetta stone.
Oh God.
Okay.
Black or Negro Roho um,
I,
I got it,
dude.
It's the shit.
It's a shit.
I'm going to be fluent in Spanish.
I've always wanted to learn another language and I ain't trying to immerse
myself.
That's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to immerse myself in the language.
I'm listening to it on the radio.
I'm also listening to it.
Uh,
you know,
I'm listening to shit like this on a,
on my iTunes,
hoping I can pick up some shit.
You know you got to,
you got to immerse yourself in the shit.
You got to listen to stuff like this.
A fucking great.
Is that got to have a fucking be able to fucking know what that means.
Sing that have pigment in my chest so I can actually wear that open.
I'm going to go stab a bull Latino shirt.
How much pussy would you get if he could fucking,
it's just unbelievable.
It's half the shit that they say.
It sounds like fucking dirty talk when you're banging a girl in a neat pivot.
Litchi that means the girl is drinking them is drinking milk.
There's no way to say that without just sounding like you're fucking,
it'll Ninette a bib and itchy.
Hey,
next time you guys are banging your girl.
Okay,
you got a Doggie style.
Just leaned down in her ear and just feel like,
ah,
maybe I need your vivid,
itchy.
Should we even have an orgasm or a fucking world around an elbow when you win
you in the face?
Either way.
Either way,
it's going to be funny,
but I want to be fluent in that shit.
And uh,
I'm liking Rosetta stone.
I really like it.
You sit there and you put on like a,
a bill,
Bellamy,
Janet Jackson Sorta headset,
you know,
and uh,
okay.
You put on some stretchy pants and then you put,
you put in the fucking CD Rom or whatever the hell it is.
And then they just,
they just start speaking to you like you're a baby sitting in the crib.
That's exactly what it is.
Two very stereotypical Mexican looking faces just sort of peer into the screen,
like you're laying in the crib and then they just start speaking to you and they
tickle your tummy.
It's,
it's tremendous.
It's a tremendous,
it's a tremendous way to numb.
I'm just fucking around dude.
It's awesome.
It's a,
if you were ever thinking about doing it,
like,
you know,
I always wanted to learn to speak a different language.
Whenever I ride the subway,
I was nervous that Puerto Rican were actually calling me bad words.
What does [inaudible] mean?
Um,
is that even Puerto Rican?
This is what's killing me.
This is how fucking what I am.
I actually believe that I'm going to learn this shit.
El Nina Bibby Litchi I'm going to learn this shit and uh,
therefore I will be able to go to Mexico,
Cuba,
Puerto Rico,
Brazil or whatever,
and be able to understand every motherfucker out there,
even though people I know this dude who is Cuban and he tells me it's,
it's really different.
Not totally different,
but I mean,
I dunno,
he seemed a little peeved when I was like,
yeah,
and I can go to fucking Cuba.
I can go to Dominican Republic.
It's not the fucking same thing.
All right,
sorry.
You know when it's one of those things,
I'm not even trying to be offensive and I offended you,
but it's like,
you know,
do you think when I go to Ireland or I went to,
went to Scotland,
I can understand those fuckers,
everything that they said,
but I knew what they were saying.
Am I being ignorant right here?
Do you guys,
is it a complete,
it's not a completely different language.
Ah,
they'll,
Nina baby Lecce you can't say that.
And fucking Cuba and they won't know what you're talking about.
Is that because it calmed me communism?
You know,
I already stopped this podcast and started it again because I'm doing this
Sunday morning.
My fucking brain isn't awake yet.
Stuttering like a goddamn jackass.
Uh,
pantaloneys spot dose will not come Isa.
I can't fucking wait.
I can't wait the first time somebody from uh,
I was going to say somebody from another language.
That's how dumb I am.
Somebody speaking Spanish talk shit about me because I'll tell you right now,
I would fucking do it all the time.
I would do it all the God damn time.
If English was a second language was not the main language of this country.
And I had another English speaking French I and,
and I was walking around people who did not understand English and it would be
our own little private language.
I would be shitting on people,
right and left perverted stuff.
Can you imagine that?
If nobody understood English,
everybody just spoke Spanish,
right?
Your boss,
some can't.
But she's got a nice rack and you sit in there and she can literally walk by and
like,
dude,
I would tit,
fuck this bitch right on a God damn desk and then turn around me all La,
me boss.
Ah,
you know,
no wonder they're so fucking laid back.
They can get it out.
I got to sit,
I got to sit on all this goddamn rage because I don't have some secret fucking
language.
All right.
Mexicans.
I mean you fucking hide out and I'm breaking down your code.
So I'm telling you this time next year,
you better watch your tongue.
Okay,
good.
Only I could turn learning in another language seat.
See you hear me stuttering.
It's in the morning.
Only I could turn speaking another language.
Am I only,
I could turn a love of language,
relax Mexico.
Just relax.
Just really listened to a couple of my podcasts and realize how fucking stupid I
am and also how I get totally psycho into something for about 10 days.
And then I just walk away from it and then it just sits there gathering dust on
my desk.
Anyways,
so it was a big week this weekend in sports.
It's actually,
uh,
what time is it?
Right now it's 10 43 and this is the funny thing.
In 17 minutes,
the World Cup final is starting,
which is basically the championship,
one of the true championships of the world.
It's the entire world competes for it.
And as big a fucking sports fan as I am,
I could give a shit.
The only thing that I would find less interesting than the World Cup final was
the Lebron James Hour long press conference to announce what team he's going to
fucking go to.
You know?
That's actually bullshit.
I totally respect the game of soccer.
It just,
it fucking bores the shit out of me.
And A,
we have a number of soccer fans on here and they send me emails and they get mad
at me.
They say,
it says,
Dear Bill Dude,
until you have a better understanding of the game,
you got to stop ragging on soccer.
Find someone that knows a little bit about the game and take some fucking time
and watch a couple of games.
Dude watch the World Cup finals.
Uh,
exclamation point.
Why?
Cause you fucking say so.
Um,
do you realize that if you added up everyone that watched the NFL,
the NBA,
the Nhl and MLB,
you would only have about half as many people that watch soccer.
Dude,
do you realize that?
I'm not so fucking stupid that I don't realize that you just pulled that stat
out of your ass.
Give me some numbers you didn't.
You said you would have about path is made about really?
Yeah.
You're going to guesstimate there.
Put that in your pipe and smoke it bill.
Thanks dude.
All right.
This is the deal.
I'm so sick of these fucking soccer cons.
Trying to convince me that it's an,
an exciting sport.
Do you think that I haven't sat down and watched it
earlier this year when I watched the Olympics,
I got into curling.
I was watching the cross country skiing.
Will you shoot the gun?
I'm very open minded when it comes to sports.
Okay.
But to sit there and killed two,
three fucking hours of my day to watch a zero to zero fucking game.
And watching these guys flop around like a bunch of Goddamn Pau Gasol every 10
fucking minutes.
It's,
it's,
I tried,
dude,
I tried it just because the whole fucking world is watching the sport.
Does it mean that I should?
All right.
The whole world was where an acid wash jeans and the life fucking eighties I
followed that trend and I got the embarrassing God damn pictures to prove it.
Where the fuck did that get me?
You know what I like about soccer?
I like the highlights,
the highlights,
you know,
and they show it in slow motion motion.
Absolutely gorgeous sport to watch.
But to sit there for fucking two hours listening to those,
God damn mosquito horns,
you,
you're really asking too much.
All right,
everybody flopping around like a bunch of God damn fucking girls.
Get off the goddamn ground.
Fucking pussies.
The guy doesn't even touch you and you flop around on the ground.
It's so a feminine.
That's what I can't stand about that sport.
You know,
this guy did bring up a good point.
He goes,
you're telling me the basketball players.
Yes,
basketball players do.
Basketball is a very fucking a feminine sport when it comes to that shit,
that fake fucking flopping around.
Yeah,
no other,
you know,
that's the closest thing.
I'm trying to think.
There's a couple of guys in the NHL,
look,
there's always going to be a couple of broads in every sport,
you know,
but at least in,
in,
in the NHL soccer fan,
you know what they have,
they have a penalty for pretending that somebody hit you two minutes.
You get,
it's called diving.
Two minutes for diving,
get up you fag and getting a goddamn penalty box.
I was,
I dunno,
I,
dude,
I tried.
I fucking tried.
I tried to watch the shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Um,
I find the Premiere League way more enjoyable to watch.
I can watch that game,
but I got to tell you like,
I don't know what it is.
I start to get a headache and I get a little bit of a stomach ache when I'm
watching it because the amount of effort that I have to put in to you know,
do,
to sit there and in two hours of your fucking life to watch a one to nothing
game.
That's why,
you know,
so I think I finally figured out why they fight in Nhl Hockey.
Cause you can actually have a one to nothing fucking games.
So you know,
then you basically have guys going,
it's legal to smash somebody's,
you know,
against the boards.
You can drop the gloves,
he could fight.
There's a lot of other exciting things that do happen.
All right?
But to sit there for two fucking hours.
Oh my God.
Ah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ooh.
Oh it's the sports equivalent to fucking blue balls.
I don't fucking it.
I really don't.
I just don't.
I don't like it.
I don't fucking like it.
Okay.
And you can't make me fucking like it because the whole world likes it.
All right.
There's,
this is a major part of the fucking world.
Did you know they,
they take out a high grade piece of sandpaper and then they,
they,
they rubbed the girl's fucking clicks off.
Does it doesn't mean that I think it's right.
Wow.
That was really disgusting.
I'm sorry.
12 minutes into the podcast,
getting that fucking gross.
I should have saved that towards the end for the diehard fans.
Um,
so anyways,
dad,
that Lebron James Announcement,
um,
speaking of mind numbingly boring.
Um,
oh,
this is not,
think about fucking soccer.
Like I'm invited to this,
this,
this party where they're going to watch the finals and whenever you find a
person who's really into soccer,
you know,
yeah,
they always get like their little soccer shirt on.
They always have like these little fucking wimpy torsos.
If you notice that it was the last time you saw somebody jacked that was into
fucking soccer,
you don't always have like those little fucking,
those little European torsos,
you know,
you little seventh grade bodies.
It does anybody lift weights or do pushups or anything in fucking Europe?
Do you just,
you just take the torso God gave you and then you just start stuffing fish and
chips down your fucking throat and you just let it all sort of slide down until
you look like Jethro Tull.
Um,
all right.
I think I've tried that shit enough.
Let's trash in American sports.
Let's talk about fucking Lebron James and his fucking,
first of all,
his howdy doody puppets shirt that he wore.
You know,
there really is this theory out there that black guys are so cool that they
really can wear any type of clothing and make it look good.
Well,
that was an example of when it doesn't quite always work.
I mean,
that was a,
I don't know what that was,
that it looked like he was going to go sing on the Grand Ole Opry in like 1948.
Um,
all right,
the fuck am I talking about?
Let's get into this whole podcast thing.
All right.
Uh,
the Lebron James one hour announcement for everybody out there who's saying how
fucking lame it was,
um,
you know who's fault that is?
It's your own God damn fault.
It's your own fucking fault for sitting there and watching it.
Okay.
It's not like ESPN lied.
They told you what it was going to be.
This is going to be a one hour special of an athlete announcing which team he's
going to go fucking play for.
I mean,
how long should that realistically take?
It's like the fucking Oscars.
How long should it take to be and to,
to take to just fucking be like,
and the Oscar goes to Sean Connery
and the Oscar for the best fucking dress in a period piece goes to Claire.
Big Billingsley
bill billings leak clear Billingsley fucking Douche bag bill burn.
Not even fucking awake trying to do a podcast to get it out of the Goddamn way
to go to some stupid ass fucking party that's showing the finals of a sport that
he doesn't give a fuck about.
That starts in nine minutes.
Oh my God.
Somebody hit fucking record.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
you know what the fuck it was going to be.
Why did you even watch it?
I mean,
can't you tell that that guy,
that guy just got some fucking horrific and he just got horrific advice from his
people around him who they were just like,
we're going to create the biggest media stir ever.
All right,
we'll go to Chicago first.
We'll gain some interest.
We'll go to the Knicks,
we'll get some interest there.
We'll go down and fuck man.
Oh,
where the fuck is he going to?
Who gives a shit?
Nobody cares except the people in those fucking touts.
I got to tell you,
I really did enjoy him.
Fucking,
you know,
terror in the hearts on a Knicks fans because as always,
New York fans are the most fucking dislike a,
that's the sense of entitlement that fans of New York sports have just because
they live in New York City.
If I have to watch one more fucking asshole on TV,
talk about the big stage in New York.
Okay.
Overrated.
Underrated for this week.
The big stage in New York,
there's only one big stage in New York.
It's in fucking Yankee stadium.
That's the only big stage that is in New York.
27 championships.
You go there,
there is pressure to win.
What does his big like when Lebron didn't pick fucking New York?
I'm on,
you know I'm online and I read three comments and I'm like,
there you go.
That's enough evidence for me.
I'm going to judge every new fan in New York right now.
They were all sitting there going like,
oh,
he was afraid of the,
the,
the bright lights.
He couldn't handle the big stage of New York.
Let me ask you this,
Nick fans,
where is the big fucking stage for professional basketball in New York City?
Madison Square Garden,
that place,
the biggest thing that happens in Madison Square Garden every year is Elton John
comes there and sell.
He fucking sells out 20 shows.
You know
Bruce Springsteen comes there and sings his songs about New Jersey.
The circus comes once a fucking year.
Those are the biggest days every year.
And Madison Square Garden.
All right,
and in case you don't know what I'm talking about,
next time you go there and there's yet another horrific played but made by
either the fucking rangers or the Knicks and you look up and discussed to that,
to the sports gods,
like what the fuck?
When you're done praying for some messiah to come in there and save those two
pathetic fucking franchises,
look up at the ceiling
and tell me what you see.
A striking lack of championship fucking banners.
I'll even give you the God damn answers.
You'd dumb fucks.
There is no big stage and it's so fucking disrespectful of everybody to say that
all the fucking time.
Talking about Amy,
you know when they talk about the biggest stage in,
in,
in major major league baseball team.
What did they say?
Fenway Park.
How about Saint Louis?
Say they got,
they got 10 fucking world series titles.
That's not even a good example.
It's not like the Knicks are in second place with titles.
Dude,
Yankee stadium is the big stage and made major league baseball.
Okay?
The fucking Celtics have 17 NBA championships that we're all one in Boston.
All right.
The Los Angeles Lakers,
11 titles have been one there a once a year they hold hands with somebody from
Minnesota and they add the five that we're in.
That's,
that's the thing right there.
The Minneapolis Lakers have more titles than the fucking New York Knicks.
Do you guys understand that?
That a team that's dead,
dead fucking moved west.
All right.
That moved fucking West around the same time the Brooklyn Dodgers went out to la
still has three more fucking titles than you do.
You don't have a big stage there and nobody is afraid to play in New York City
and there's certainly not afraid to play the fucking Knicks,
so get off your own dicks.
I'm sick of it.
All right.
The jets having wanted since 69 the Knicks haven't worn it since 73 the mets
haven't won it since fucking 86
who else has left?
The giants are,
are a respectable franchise.
That's the best you have.
You have a respectable franchise that is one the same amount of super bowls as
the Patriots,
the packers,
the Redskins,
and the Raiders.
The giants are in the middle of the pack.
All right?
There's no big fucking stage.
And they sit there and they act like these sports writers in New York,
these fat mantated jackasses,
these fill mushed nics are going intimidate a guy at the level of fucking Lebron
James.
They're not.
I hate to tell it to you in New York.
The reason why he didn't go to Madison Square Garden is cause you suck.
That's why,
I mean think about that.
Who the fuck wouldn't want to go play in New York?
You know New York is the city is the Paris of fucking of America.
It's the best fucking city we have.
All right,
but just because there's a bunch of people outside of Madison Square Garden
succeeding and doing some shit,
most of whom aren't even from New York by the way.
That's another thing.
New Yorkers think they're the shit just because live there just
because they're standing on the corner of fucking 52nd and third eaten a slice.
You know,
if I can get there,
I'll make an ad anywhere.
Are you really making it with your dirty fucking sneakers standing there outside
of Tad's steaks.
You're not doing shit.
None of you are all you fucking pieces of Shit fucking gathering outside of
fucking port authority.
That's another thing.
Oh Man,
I'm trashing the York this week.
I don't give a fuck.
Listen me,
I don't give a fuck who bill.
Really?
You're being dangerous.
It's dangerous to make
yeah,
alone.
Bray and a danger resold.
Um,
do Frank Sinatra's from New Jersey.
Okay.
He was bridge and tunnel.
The kindness,
the kind of guy that Paris Hilton wouldn't have fucked in one of her whore
nightclubs down there in the meat packing district.
If he came in and said,
oh,
I live in Hoboken,
she would have turned a little pointy nose up to the ceiling and walked away or
in a big fucking Sasquatch feet that she tries to hide.
Bye Jack.
And a God damn fucking ass in the air to eye level.
No girls would have banged that guy.
But what did he do?
He came in there,
he came in there and he fucking sang a song and he took over your fucking city.
The way a bunch of people from other states that you fucking New Yorkers looked
down on.
We come in there all the time.
We come in there and we blow away half to fuck a talent in New York because you
guys are standing there eating a slice of pizza,
looking at the fucking empire state building going,
oh,
it's open all night.
You're not doing shit.
You don't have a big stage.
You have a sorry ass fucking NBA team.
You know this.
How dumb the fucking nics are.
Isaiah Thomas,
there was a league called the CBA that did find for like 30 fucking years.
And then what's his face?
Isaiah Thomas.
Thomas became president of the league and in life,
three,
four years.
I don't have the fucking stats.
I Dunno.
Five years it went out of business.
Okay.
I'm not talking about,
you know,
a winning franchise went to a losing franchise.
I'm not talking about a franchise that existed in a city,
had to move.
I'm not even saying the franchise folded.
I'm talking about an entire fucking league.
He got it to controls.
He pushed the yolk forward and just flew the shit right into the goddamn ground.
All right?
And like bugs bunny.
He stepped out right before it hit the ground before any of it got on him.
And then the next go.
Yet that's our guy.
That's the guy we're going to get to run the fucking NBA franchise.
The guy who fucking flew bootleg NBA,
the Goddamn ground.
That's the fucking dude.
See,
that's why Lebron didn't come.
Not because he's afraid of the big stage.
You want to know who's afraid of the big stage?
Jeff Weaver.
Jeff Weaver was afraid of the big stage.
Okay?
But Lebron James is not afraid of the big at the big stage.
He could fucking put his nuts on Jeff weavers chest and hold them down in the
deep end of a fucking pool.
All right?
He's not afraid of fucking Madison Square Garden.
And I also thought it was really fucking ironic
that of the three emails that I read by New Yorkers,
which I'm now judging all of them,
they were going like,
you know,
Miami.
That's Dwayne Wade's town.
If he goes down there and wins a championship there,
nobody's going to respect him.
Can you fucking believe a New Yorker had the balls to say that with the fucking
pile on team that the Yankees have been for the last 12 fucking years?
Every God damn free agent on the fucking planet just clinging to Derek Jeters
leg.
Show me how to do it.
I want to win one too.
Huh?
Roger Clemens,
that fed buffalo wing.
Eaton Jackass.
Was it hard up in Toronto?
Roger.
Then he fucking comes down there and jumps in the fucking Limo.
The fucking balls of these New York fans to sit there and question somebody's
piling on another team to go in a fucking championship.
I,
I can't even take it.
I think I got to drink some throat coat tea that I mentioned that on this
podcast cause I already deleted the other one when I was annoyed with how
fucking unfunny I was.
I'm great.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and say that the ratings for this in New York
City are going to be kind of low this week.
I got to throw Coty,
which is great.
If you stand on stage and you don't know how to write a joke and you have to
scream at jokes,
or even if you'd like to call your girlfriend account at the top of your lungs,
you know you have a do that and then the next day you want to do it again,
but you throw these two tore up.
You can't do it well,
get organic throat coat tea,
everybody.
You could call your girl a cunt seven days a week,
365 days a year.
That'd be a great commercial,
right?
Just have the girl crying in the background,
sitting down in the fetal position as you're fucking sitting in the field.
Fetal position bill curled up in the fetal position bill,
he had dumped,
fuck,
all right,
let's see.
What did I do so far in this podcast?
I pissed off anyone who isn't from America or I guess you know,
Americans who are also into soccer.
And then I trashed a,
a giant media market.
See right there,
Bill.
That's why New York is such the big stage because it's one of the biggest media
markets in all of the fucking cook for you.
How pathetic are you fucking teams that you got to bring up the level of media
in your city,
the level of media gimme a fucking break.
Two Championship banners,
1970 fucking three.
Do you know in 1973,
the Chevy Vega was considered a sports car.
And if you go on the game show network,
people lose their fucking minds about that car,
you know,
and you can win.
And then they opened the kernel,
bright little Chevy Vega and these people with their fucking big Greg,
Greg Bay,
Brady fucking belt buckles,
and they're fucking,
uh,
who's that dude from?
Knocked up,
observe and report the Seth Rogen fucking Afros go absolutely fucking ape shit
over a Chevy Vega.
That's when you guys want it.
Last.
People from are dying of old fucking age on that team.
Who did you have an idea?
Who are the fucking,
the Nix,
the greats.
Who Do you got?
Bill Bradley.
Daddy became a senator and then he fucking died.
This is what it is.
You want to get down to brass tacks here?
What's really bugging me is,
uh,
in Boston we only have four sports teams.
Okay?
We're playing a fucking,
you know,
we got one,
one bullet in the chamber and those cunts down there in New York,
they're doubled down in two out of the four fucking sports every year.
This split and fucking aces in two different sports.
So they pad their stats with championships.
But I respect the Yankees.
The Yankees are the greatest franchise in an an all for sports.
They got the fucking championships.
You have to respect it.
They got them.
And I would never ever try to act like somebody was afraid to play in Boston
because of the media or whatever the fuck that you know or call it the big stage
in Boston.
All right.
I would never do that out of respect for the fucking Yankees.
The fact that they have 20 more fucking championships than we do.
Okay,
so give me the fucking respect that I deserve as a Boston Celtics Fan,
that we have 15 more fucking NBA championships than you do fucking idiots.
The big stage.
I'm so sick of these fat mantated shitheads with their fucking game worn jerseys
and they yell shit at players on the field and they think that they're
intimidating them.
You know like the fact that you got a d up Koby Bryant that you know that night
isn't enough to make you nervous?
No,
it's the fat fuck with the shaved head and fucking row 58 g
who Stew's Chanten airball air.
They don't care.
Then even fucking hear it.
They don't even hear it.
Lebron James is not afraid to go to New York.
He wanted to win.
All right?
That's why the fuck he went to Miami.
But uh,
you know,
and I would really love it and this is the deal if,
if the fucking Lakers didn't exist,
um,
with this stupid tee shirts claiming that the Los Angeles Lakers have fucking
16,
because that's what the t shirt says.
It says Los Angeles Lakers 16 championships,
not Los Angeles Slash Minneapolis Lakers.
Um,
so now I have to become a Miami heat fan.
I really do.
But just for the record,
dude,
I don't like any of this shit.
I didn't like the 2008 Boston Celtics.
I didn't like that either.
Where you just go out and,
and just everybody piles on one team.
I don't fucking like it.
I don't like this age of the super teams.
It's a,
yeah.
And I don't even,
that's not,
I don't know what it is anymore.
It's like,
it's like,
uh,
it's sports of becoming like what Ruth retail stores have become.
They're all like these superstores now.
There's not like just the regular hardware store.
That example,
I use every podcast.
It's always a hardware store with me,
but fucking one trick pony.
It's all fucking,
it's all Walmarts now.
Home depots best buys,
all of that type of shit.
And uh,
I dunno,
it's not the same kind of pride like that that you had back in the day when you
watched red Arrow back get some unknown center from Golden State.
You know Robert Parish,
who the fuck knew who he was before he came to the Celtics and he goes after
Kevin Mchale was in a highly touted draft pick and then Larry Bird,
he works on for like three fucking years and gets them to come to the Celtics
like that with some interesting shit.
But nowadays when you got shit like Kevin Mchale,
a former Celtic is working for the grizzlies and he gives the fucking Celtics
Kevin Garnett for nothing,
for nothing.
Decimates an entire fucking franchise.
The same way Jerry West is fucking working for Memphis and gives the fucking
Lakers Pau Gasol for nothing.
I mean,
it's a,
I don't know,
I don't fucking know.
And the fact that these fucking knick fans are sitting there talking about that
guy piling on as the god Damn Yankees are Erin negotiations to try to get cliff
Lee.
Like they don't have enough with fucking Subathra Aja Burnett,
Marianna Rivera,
fucking Alex Rodriguez,
Al fucking to share all those guys.
I love all the names of fading away cause I don't even watch baseball anymore.
It's such a fucking stupid God damn sport.
Um,
do it.
If the Yankees got cliff Lee,
you might as well just mail them the trophy,
you know,
and um,
this is what it is.
I Dunno if I'm just this crabby old man.
I'm really trying to find the art in,
uh,
signing all these free agents because it just seems to me like whoever has the
most fucking money will eventually get most of the best guys.
You know,
occasionally you'll lose out on a guy,
occasionally a cliff Lee,
we'll go to the rangers,
you know,
or somebody will pick the fucking angels or maybe they'll go to the fucking red
sox or something like that.
But generally speaking,
you start with the fucking Yankees and then it just goes down.
I Dunno,
I just doesn't seem like there's any fucking skill that I had just been of a
five.
You know what it is.
I'm on my fucking period this week,
half hour a rag and about that shit.
Let's get to,
uh,
let's see.
Let's just totally fucking,
uh,
make a left turn here.
And,
uh,
somebody asked me some for some advice this week.
All right,
here we go.
This is,
this is now,
this is a quote.
This is a situation that I think a lot of people that all embrace can deal with.
Um,
let's see here.
Uh,
hey bill,
huge fan.
Love you.
Comedy a with the hope this won't get too long.
Um,
it starts with one of my good friends going out with this girl.
Uh,
they went out for about a,
uh,
right off the bat,
you know,
he can't,
can't you tell where this is going?
This story starts with one of my good friends going out with this girl.
They went out for about a year or two on honor,
on and off.
Come on bill.
Focus here.
Just try to read this smoothly.
All right,
let's start over and it starts with one of my good friends going out with this
girl.
They went out for about a year or two on and off.
I'm still though,
even when they were together,
they were never really good in quotes.
Here we go.
They fought basically all the time and just didn't seem right for each other
though.
Gee,
you know where this is going during the early stages of their relationship.
My friend thought I had a thing for her.
Ogz She's a,
she is a good looking girl.
She is a good looking girl and I was friends with her before they even got
together.
Dude,
you are so justifying what the fuck you either did or about ready to do.
I love it.
They weren't really good for each other.
Even when they were together,
they just,
there was something missing.
I actually knew her before he did.
Um,
here we go.
She is a good looking girl and I was friends with there before they were even
together.
I admit I might have inadvertently been a little flirty with her sometimes.
Oh,
I'm sorry it was I just flirting there.
There you have a future at uh,
at BP the next time they pollute an entire Gulf of a nation that they're not
even citizens of and they need to bring somebody out to stand behind the podium
through.
This is fucking great.
I might have inadvertently been a little flirty with her.
How the fuck do you even do that?
How do you inadvertently flirt with somebody?
Wow.
You really look beautiful in that dress.
I'll tell you if you were my girlfriend,
I have ever Devin.
I mean,
wait,
what the fuck do you go with?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
That's right.
You're now my girlfriend.
I'm sorry.
I thought you were my girlfriend for a second.
What was I thinking?
Jesus Christ.
I'm so embarrassed and my face turning red.
Oh my God.
I was just inadvertently flirting with you.
Right then.
Uh,
Jesus.
here we go.
But any,
he goes,
this is what he says.
I might have inadvertently been a little flirty with her sometimes,
but that shit always happens with a guy and a girl.
I think,
dude,
the level of guilt just weighing you down as you're trying to justify all of
this.
Uh,
either way I told him,
um,
I didn't like her,
which was true dude,
stop lying to yourself.
Anyways,
it passed.
However,
I always got this feeling that there was a,
there was still an undertone that he resented me since then.
Yeah.
Probably because of all the inadvertent flirting and the fact that you were
emoting that they weren't right for each other.
Um,
but anyways,
let's,
let's fast forward as he says,
fast forward now.
They've been broken up for at least a year and don't talk.
She says,
uh,
he randomly texted her,
Texas,
her text her,
Jesus Christ,
I can't even fucking read.
She says he randomly texted her,
but uh,
that she doesn't ever answer him.
But regardless of that,
now this girl likes me.
What?
Oh my God,
I didn't see that coming.
Wait a minute.
Anyways,
but she actually likes me and basically says she wants to fuck my voice,
just cracked in the perfect
says she wants to fuck.
Am I getting excited?
I need some more throat coat here and basically says she wants to fuck.
Um,
she tells me stuff like she wishes she went out with me instead of him to begin
with.
Now I do all right with girls,
but I don't have them lining up or anything.
So I'm not trying to let a virtual shirt thing pass me by.
Oh my God.
And this is when it's getting Jerry Springer here.
Uh,
with most guys I don't,
I,
I'd feel like they'd not care if I went for it or at least understand why I did.
Did you realize what you're saying?
I think most guys wouldn't care if their best friend went out and bang their
fucking ex-girlfriend within a year of them going out.
I think that they'd understand.
So anyways,
he goes,
so I think most guys want to stand,
but this buddy of mine is a little nuts and it's also a situation where he's the
type of guy that if he were in my position,
he do the same thing.
Ah Dude,
you just justifying.
You don't even need my advice,
you're going to do it.
Um,
my other friend who knows the whole situation says I should,
but others I've talked to about it.
Say I shouldn't.
Uh,
the last I talked to her,
she said she wanted to hang out just me and her and then I should let her know
when I want to.
Uh,
all right.
I guess this thing's getting kind of long.
I have one question.
Do I have any justification and fucking this girl and two,
if I do,
would you say I should go through with it?
Okay.
All right,
sir.
There there's just this just a ton of shit going on here.
Okay.
Right off the bat,
you have to be honest with yourself.
All right?
You weren't inadvertently f a flirting with this girl.
You actually probably,
uh,
like this girl before this guy even got with her,
or maybe the fact that the guy,
your friend got worth there and he was banging her,
made you all of a sudden interested in her.
See,
I don't know,
you as a person,
you could be a very sadistic,
a human being.
Actually,
I'm going to go on a limb and say you're not,
because the fact that you actually give a fuck enough to write me and ask
whether you should do this,
that means you actually have some sort of guilt about it.
Um,
so you won't get off on banging your fucking,
uh,
best friend's ex girlfriend,
through this.
A lot of shit here that could blow up in your face.
Okay?
In a perfect world.
All right.
You're a man and you say,
you know what,
uh,
that's not going to be worth the,
the,
the blowback.
It's not going to be worth the fucking damage that I'm going to do.
This guy's my best friend.
I,
even though he would do it to me,
I'm not going to do it to him.
And then I also need to stop being friends with this guy because anybody who
would go out and fuck my ex girlfriend within a year is not truly a friend.
I need to get better friends.
But despite all that,
I'm still not going to do what the fuck he would have done just because he would
have done it to me.
And you just walk away from the situation and you go out and you chat up some
other fucking broads.
That's,
that is like,
if you want to be knighted someday,
buy one of those fucking broads over there and a in the castle in England,
you know,
if you want to go over there with Surf Surf Phil Collins looking on
and get knighted,
that's what the fuck you do.
But if you're going to bang this broad,
um,
you've already fucked up.
Okay.
Fucking your best friend's ex girlfriend.
It's like committing a murder you want is few people involved is humanly
possible.
I learned that on an episode of uninformed when we had a cop come in and me and
my,
uh,
cohost Joe to Rosa were saying that,
um,
you know,
we were trying to come up with how to commit the perfect murder.
And I remember said,
okay,
I'd get me and a buddy of mine,
he goes right there,
you fucked up right there.
You fucked up.
He goes,
the more people you bring in,
the bigger chance you have of getting caught,
you know,
cause you're not going to rat yourself out.
But the other guy,
if he gets scared,
might go down to the police station and try to cop a plea.
All right?
That's the same shit with this.
If you're going to fuck your best friend's girl,
ex-girlfriend,
you don't go around and ask other friends going,
dude,
should I do with you?
Don't.
And you already did.
All right.
And then the other side of it is,
um,
I don't know how the two of these people broke up,
but uh,
you know,
Hell hath no fury like a woman scorned.
And for all,
you know,
this chick might be a fucking psycho.
All right.
I mean,
I think it's a good thing that he's texting her and not the other way around and
that she is not texting him back.
Granted,
you're taking her word for it,
that that's what the situation is now.
For all you know,
it's the reverse and if it is the reverse,
she wants some sort of vengeance,
which means she goes out and bangs his best friend and then Lo and behold feels
guilty the next day and then has to tell him,
all right,
just to let you know that is on the fucking table.
If you really want to know whether or not you want a jerk,
if you want to jerk,
if you want to fucking,
I got ahead of myself here.
If you want to fuck this girl and not just go jerk off to her and after you'd
done,
if you still want a Banger,
you want a banger and then just fucking man up and deal with the fucking
consequences of it and go out and bang her because who gives a fuck as someday
you're going to be 80 and who gives a shit,
you know?
Or on the other side,
if you actually have feelings for this girl,
that's a whole,
then you should definitely do it.
If you actually feel like this girl could be the girl that you're going to spend
your life with,
then I would definitely say go for it.
Knowing full well that your friendship with this other guy is,
uh,
is going to end.
Um,
I dunno.
So dude it,
you know what,
it's,
it's fucking on you.
You know,
if you asked me what I do at a,
yeah,
I would have,
back in the day I would have,
but now that I'm an older,
wiser man,
I wouldn't,
I would just fucking rub one out to her and then be afterwards going,
oh,
thank God I didn't fucking do that.
Thank God I didn't do that.
And I was,
I would also fucking not hang out with the other guy because any guy friend of
mine that would fuck an ex girlfriend of mine within a fucking year,
I wouldn't want to be friends with,
even though I just described all of my friends
do it.
I don't know what to tell.
I don't know what to tell you.
You probably shouldn't do what you should.
You shouldn't do.
Just shut.
And you should go out and go fucking bank somebody else.
You shouldn't.
All right.
But I feel like a hypocrite because I would,
I would.
But then again,
I'm also a fucking 42 year old guy.
Oh,
never got married.
So when,
so you're listening to a complete fucking scumbag here.
So Jesus Christ,
this is why I don't have a fucking advice show,
you know,
because in my attempt to be honest,
I,
I tell you both things,
do it.
Don't do it.
I would,
but you shouldn't have a nice day.
Um,
you know what?
Let's,
let's go to the listeners.
I would love to hear from the women because they,
they're going to have on both sides.
They're going to have like,
you shouldn't do that,
your friend.
And then they're also going to be mad on some level.
Like why did guys feel like they own somebody just because they youth to go out
with them?
Because we're territorial with territorial that way.
And you have to understand that whoever you've banged in your life as a female,
um,
for the rest of your life,
that pussy is not yours anymore.
It belongs to him.
And you can say it's yours.
It isn't because he fucked it.
All right?
You know what?
I feel like,
you know,
there wasn't enough ignorance on this podcast,
so I feel like I had to just say something stupid like that.
But that's,
that's how guys work.
And,
um,
I'd even asked you,
this is your best friend.
Is he bigger than you are physically?
Can he beat you down?
Does he take Jujitsu classes?
Um,
has he ever had any murderous thoughts that he,
I'm sort of divulge to you at an,
you know,
a night of drinking too many Tequila shots and you see an a and the darker side
of him,
you know,
there's,
there's a whole bunch of Shit,
ah,
this is what she got to do.
This is what you gotta do.
Go out and get yourself a fucking pimp hat.
All right?
And this is what you have to do.
You got to go to this girl and you,
you just gotta lay it on the fucking table.
That's what you gotta do.
You just gotta be honest with her and just say,
look
sweetheart,
I have wanted to fuck you since 2006.
You don't say that,
but basically you finish your way into that.
You got to tell her that you've wanted to hook up with her.
And the only reason why you didn't,
this is the deal.
This is
all right.
Well,
we had a little technical difficulty there.
I left you hanging.
Sorry about that.
The batteries just died.
I was right in the middle of trying to tell this dude how we could,
uh,
go out and bang this girl.
Now I got to fucking stick this into the goddamn garage band.
Splice it together,
which I already did at this point.
So why even bitch about it when you listen to this fucking thing?
All right,
let me wrap this God damn podcast up a telling this kid how to go out and fuck
his best friend's ex girlfriend.
All right.
This is what you do.
You got to,
you got to have a talk with this girl before you do it.
Don't just go over there and just fucking sneak over there.
You know,
with this nervous excitement,
fucking rail,
this girl bust your nut and then realize,
oh my God,
I have no fucking feelings for this girl.
And then you know,
risking that she'll then,
you know,
be resentful.
All the bullshit I said in the first fucking installment of this God damn
podcast,
this is what you gotta do.
You gotta fucking get everything out in the open.
All right?
And fucking let her convince you that it's the right fucking thing to do and get
her to say that she ain't gonna say shit.
All right.
Get her to say that.
And when she says she's not going to say shit,
you have to reader.
All right?
Like a fucking seasoned goddamn pro.
You know,
the 27 fucking uh,
pantomimes align,
whatever that fucking goddamn movie was true romance.
You got to look at her and Jay.
You,
you have to,
you have to make a fucking assessment.
If this girl can keep her fucking mouth shut
by presenting these scenarios,
you've got to be,
look,
I'm going to get worried that tomorrow.
What if you,
you're going to wake up feeling guilty and then you have to confess to him,
you know,
I'm not going to feel,
I'm not going to feel guilty.
Yeah,
you are.
You're just fucking,
I don't know.
I'm really giving you shit advice,
dude.
I'm,
I'm trying to give you a fucking scumbag way to go out and go do this shit.
Just like,
I dunno.
I'm fucking bad at this,
man.
I have to be in the moment to what the fuck?
Dirt Bag,
God damn thing.
What I be saying.
All right,
this is what you do.
You don't go over a fucking,
Don't go over a goddamn place.
See,
this is the hard thing.
Now you've got to go out.
You've got to meet her in public.
Okay?
So there's no sexual fucking tension that you can act on.
All right?
So you,
Dick won't be like,
dude,
she's fine.
She's not lying.
She's going to be cool.
What you have to do is,
um,
you're going to meet in a public place where then people can see a c two.
This is just,
it's just the fuck.
It's a,
it's a tough one.
Tell you what to it.
If you can actually fucking pull this off,
why don't you write me back and tell you,
tell me how you,
how the fuck he did it.
I remember a long time ago,
I was in the beginning of a relationship and I was banging this,
still banging this other psycho on the side.
And,
uh,
like a dirt bag,
you know?
And I remember there was going to be a point where the two of them were going to
be at the same fucking place.
So I just dealt with it before.
It wasn't before we hooked up.
I just said,
look,
you've got to be honest with you.
This girl I'm coming down with,
we're new,
I'm starting to have feelings for all right.
I told her that I cleaned up everything on the side,
which I haven't with you,
so I need you to not act weird when I fucking come down there.
If I don't,
you know,
if I'm not saying hello to you.
Okay.
That was before I hooked up with her and she's like,
fine,
fine.
And then she went down there and then she did at cool because in her head she's
probably holding out like maybe if I had cool,
he'll see how fucking cool I am and they don't want to be with me and not this
other bitch.
And meanwhile I fucking got away with it.
And you know what a part of me died.
Another fucking chunk of my soul came out and said,
dirty fucking game.
It's a dirty God damn game.
I'm a piece of shit.
Don't fucking listen to me.
All right,
what else do we got this week?
But by the way,
dude,
now that I've talked about it for 10 fucking minutes,
you got,
you got to write a Spec and let us know what happened.
All right?
You know,
I realize this might be like one of those stupid Hollywood movies.
And then I realized that's not the person I wanted to be doing.
If you do that,
I don't want to fucking hear it.
But if you done,
if you do the dirty bullshit,
I want to hear about it.
Would I be the worst fucking life coach ever?
Um,
all right,
here's a,
here's a segment,
corporate cons.
A bill for someone who flies as much as you do.
Can you take a shot at explaining the logic behind why a one way ticket almost
costs more than a round trip.
Um,
for a domestic,
for domestic flights,
maybe this isn't a problem.
However,
I'm flying from your,
uh,
from Europe at the end of the month on a one way ticket,
and it costs one and a half times more than a round trip trip ticket.
And I immediately said,
well,
why don't you buy the round trip ticket?
And he addresses this immediately and says,
and if the airline company can prove that I purchased a roundtrip ticket,
it was the attempt of not using the return for the flight.
They can legally charge for the price difference between the fares.
What the fuck is this normal business practice?
I hate to tell you what,
but it is because that's how corrupt our fucking government is.
That's how powerful corporations are around the fucking world.
They,
they do whatever they,
whatever they want to do.
And they have this thing where every quarter they have to show a profit.
All right?
Uh,
actually they have to,
to,
to show more of a profit than the previous quarter.
They can't even just have the same amount of profit.
It's not enough.
And basically,
they've legally run out of ways to create revenue streams.
So what they're doing now is they're just stealing.
They're stealing from people.
All right?
If you have a one way ticket,
that means you're going home or you're starting a new life and you want to get
the fuck out of where you're at.
So that's why they know that they can charge you a ton of fucking money.
All right?
And then,
well,
what are some buys?
A round trip ticket,
then we'll fucking,
we'll just write this little bill here and we'll have the senator who we fucking
paid for his God damn campaign help push it through.
Isn't that how it works?
They just call the senator.
I don't know anything.
Um,
yeah,
no,
it's a piece of shit thing.
So what you gotta do is you have to vandalize the airplane.
All right?
Do something to vandalize the fucking airplane.
I don't even do that cause all they're going to do is just pass that expense on
to us.
This is what you have to do.
Um,
you have to find out who it is that came up with that,
who created that?
Who was,
uh,
who was the lobbyist who push that thing through how that somehow became legal.
You got to find out where they live and then you just gotta.
You gotta tailor them the whole fucking week.
Get that patterns down,
figure out when they go to the Goddamn Gym.
Alright,
borrow a pair of pantyhose from your fucking girlfriend,
put it over your head,
hide in some shrubs.
And when that dude comes walking out of the gym with that fucking towel around
his neck,
you just blast him right in the face and then you fucking choke them with your,
choke them.
You mushes face into the mulch
and you'd be like,
that's what a one way ticket from fucking Hollenback to the state yet content.
And then you get your fucking Ford Festiva and you drive away.
That's the only way to get back at him.
And,
uh,
and if you do that,
I'll give you a free DVD,
a underrated overrated for the week,
uh,
underrated,
the movie waiting.
Uh,
it's all about the world of restaurant,
waiters,
cooks,
et cetera.
It's funny,
honest,
and quite gross.
I imagine it is because I've worked in a couple of fucking restaurants and the
shit that goes on,
you know,
the shit that you'll do when you're not cooking for a family member is really a,
it's staggering.
I'll leave it at that.
Um,
overrated.
How,
and this is pretty bitter.
But anyways,
when you watch the special features on a DVD and there's always the making of
feature,
far too many of these features,
including the movie waiting,
then I just recommended have the actors and the directors jokingly calling
others on the film,
useless,
awful,
amateur,
amateurish,
et cetera.
Uh,
they'll talk about how the whole film is a disaster and it will,
uh,
and we'll go straight to video.
Get it.
They don't really mean it.
They're joking around.
Lol,
lol.
See I told you it was a bitter one.
Yeah,
I guess,
you know,
I kind of understand.
I mean,
how many times can you just sit there and go,
Ashton Kutcher with absolutely brilliant in Madame of the butterfly,
the butterfly effect whenever the fuck it was called.
Um,
that seeing his reaction here is right up with Bruce Willis in die hard part
three when he turns around and looks at the green screen and pretends to be
looking at a jumbo jet.
It's was absolutely some of the best act.
I mean,
how long could you listen to that?
So they got to make fun of themselves.
Um,
I would go with arrogance.
I would just talk about my scenes and how fucking amazing I am.
Um,
while I was pointing out the dumb shit that I did in it,
uh,
youtube videos for the week and do I,
I'm going to tell you,
man,
I think I'm recommended or at least the listeners of my podcast,
we're recommended some of the funniest and best fucking,
uh,
youtube videos out there.
How great would those youtube videos last week?
You know,
all right,
here's one duck face song search,
duck face song like quack,
quack,
duck face song.
And this is an amazing one.
Search fake Yo yo,
trickster fool's.
Every TV station everywhere.
I mean,
granted it could have been shorter but fake Yoyo trickster fool's,
every TV station everywhere.
This is hilarious.
This guy goes on and he claims to be a Yoyo champion and he actually sucks at it
and he talks all this shit and then he goes on there and he can't pull off any
tricks and he just stands there and leaves the morning news guy with the
awkwardness of him completely failing and not handling the failing and just
leaving it in the lap of the reporter and it's a,
it's fucking awesome.
Um,
AH,
here's one for all you kids and I'm going to use the young kid word.
This one is epic.
Um,
this one isn't on Youtube.
This is how cutting edge the Monday morning podcast is.
Uh,
go to www.everythingisterrible.com.
And then search for the video.
This is hip hop and uh,
it's awesome.
It's a fucking white lady.
Soccer mom,
you know,
and she's going to let you know what time it is.
I want to leave it at that.
Everything is terrible.com.
Um,
a couple more,
uh,
for all unique fans out there who will,
licking your wounds,
go to go search a Lebron James Decision interview parody.
I think you'll enjoy that one immensely.
Uh,
fro you death metal fans who have a sense of humor.
And because this one really hinges on actually knowing the song,
there's a band called Cannibal corpse and the name of the song is hammer smashed
face.
And if you don't already know that song,
I suggest you listen to it first.
Listened to Cannibal corpse hammer smashed face for as long as you can,
unless you're death metal fan.
And then you'll love it,
um,
or a fan of comedy.
Um,
and then go to search,
Cannibal Corpse Hammer,
smashed face,
smash face,
Disney radio version.
Some fucking genius out there.
Basically,
you know,
I guess death metals,
a lot of like,
I dunno,
the darker chords and he turned them all,
plays the same court but in a major court,
which are the happier ones.
And then he sings the song with the same lyrics.
It's fucking great.
Um,
and that is it.
You know what,
I didn't bring up asides from for hyping the month,
uh,
the FM podcast.com,
um,
is,
I and all of this Lebron Shit,
I didn't really bring up like the fans of fucking Cleveland and yet another
fucking blow that those people have to take.
I mean,
it just,
it's brutal between the industry leaving that town and then I'll,
you know,
cc Sabathia he went,
ended up going in New York,
Manny Ramirez went to Boston.
Jim Tome may went to Philly.
I mean they had the team and now they finally get like fucking arguably I would
say the next Coby level player.
He's got a way to go.
But the next Coby level pay a player in Lebron James gave him a reason to go to
the downtown area.
It sucks.
It sucks because downtown Cleveland,
if you really look at the buildings,
if he can look past the scary homeless people in really look at the buildings,
uh,
it's beautiful.
It's just that,
you know,
getting back to these corporate cons,
they just pulled up stakes and they left because they were sick of paying people
a fair wage.
And they were sick of having to pay for health insurance and they wanted to have
some eight year old go put the fucking grill on a God damn fucking caprice
classic.
I don't fucking though,
same thing with Detroit.
Those all those cities,
Buffalo,
all of them.
If you look at him,
the buildings,
they're very,
they're,
they're beautiful cities and you can see what they used to be and it's,
it's a fucking shame.
Um,
I dunno,
I dunno how to bring them back,
you know,
buy American,
which is why I'm going to get the fucking challenger.
Okay.
And if I find out that it's actually put together down and fucking Honduras,
I'm going to be fucking pissed.
All right.
Al Challenger is dodge not put together in fucking whatever the fucking thing
is.
I'm going to learn Spanish,
God dammit.
And I'm going to have two podcasts.
I'll have one in fucking,
uh,
on glaze in one in fucking espanol.
Would that be great?
Then I could,
then I could actually trash people in their native language about how much
soccer is fucking boring.
All right.
That is a,
that's a podcast for this week.
Um,
once again,
thanks for everybody's contributing.
Please visit the MM podcast.com if you want,
if you don't want to search youtube,
it's a fucking pain in the ass or then you got to go to why everything is
terrible.com.
If you just want them all in a night.
Nice,
neat little package.
Like those little fucking things.
You know when you,
when you girls got a birthday and you just go down to the spine,
you get her little fucking fancy soaps and everything.
We got youtube videos pack.
It's just like that with a nice little bow on them.
And uh,
all the references that I make like Bill Bradley and all that bullshit,
go to the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Uh,
I'm going to be at the Montreal comedy festival this week.
I'll be doing David Letterman next week,
but um,
that's neither here nor there because I'll be doing a podcast next Monday before
I tape it any way.
So I can talk to you guys about what it's like to be sitting around the day of
doing a David Letterman spot.
That is it.
God bless you.
I'll talk to you later.
[inaudible] [inaudible].